thousands of migrants remain in del rio
texas at this hour man or the haitians
have now left the encampment you're
seeing on your screen the white house
conceded today that it has no idea where
they are
where they went
we just pause and note that this is not
a disaster
it's not a crisis
this is criminal behavior
this is the executive branch of
government intentionally subverting
federal law
encouraging the breaking of american law
abetting crimes this is criminal
behavior
the white house is doing nothing about
it because they caused it they didn't
announce the border patrol is now
prohibited from using horses at the
border because the real crime is against
the people trying to break into our
country not against the country itself
notice all of our time has been spent
concerned about the people trying to
break our laws and none of the time
in the national media or even in our
national political conversations in
either party
has been devoted to the americans who
are suffering because of this which is
all 340 million of us but it's
particularly the americans who live in
south texas towns like uvalde
dom mclaughlin is the mayor of evaldi
texas he joins us tonight for an update
on how things are going mr mayor thanks
so much for coming on how are things
going
well thank you for having me uh
it's pretty much a clown show i mean
it's uh
the borders wide open all the
checkpoints are closed from west texas
all the way to below del rio the foot
traffic has increased tenfold
the human smuggling has increased
tenfold there's no border patrol agents
available they're all down at del rio uh
processing haitians
it's just it's just getting
crazier and crazier and crazier and
these these peaceful uh immigrants
illegal immigrants they keep talking
about are getting more and more
aggressive with landowners they're doing
more destruction to property they're
tearing things up
trash and ranch houses trashing vehicles
and you know
you can complain all you want but this
this administration turns a blind eye to
it
this is such a failed administration and
a fellow president it's terrible
it's shocking it's well it's criminal
they're abetting crimes
will
will you or anybody else in your
community or in that region expect to
get reimbursed by the federal government
for the damage caused by these new
democratic voters that they're letting
in
well i said now you mentioned i sent
today
pictures uh on a piece of property that
we have where they trashed the property
cut the fences in two times uh have
pictures of them walking across the
property and that and i sent that out to
all my
federally elected officials today since
immigration is the government's uh baby
who do i send the bill to for repent
making these repairs i haven't got a
response yet
yeah i suspect you nor is any other
rancher down there
the rest of the country really i mean i
think we're all going to be affected by
this but you're affected by it first and
most profoundly you know just our hearts
go out to you mayor dom mclaughlin of
ivaldi texas thanks for coming on
tonight
yes sir thank you